so we're a few months in and Barack
Hussein Obama has been spending money
like Billie Joe Armstrong at an Avon
party which begs the question
at the time of this video Barack Obama
has already signed off on more spending
than has taken place from the conception
of the United States to his inauguration
slow down little guy pace yourself
you're gonna get a tummy ache of course
the most noteworthy of as spending
escapades is the stimulus package
stimulus package and a whopping 1.1 four
trillion dollars it's a hefty little
bill I'm just a boo
yeah I'm just a bill did you get a
chance to read it yet don't worry mayor
did Obama or most of our representatives
which is why we've done the work for you
this chart shows where the stimulus
money is actually going go ahead and
take your time so we know where the
stimulus money is going on paper but I
haven't seen any stimulus money have you
have you received any stimulus money yet
no not directly no I have not no no no
so that's to make sure that's a double
no didn't think so so I took an employee
from the PJTV studio and decided to find
it myself hey what's your name
Steve yeah you got a car
and then hit the road the first thing
that caught our interest on our stimulus
search popped up in the most unexpected
place we are on our way to the North
Shore Yacht Club by the Salton Sea
because word on the street is that they
got three point something million
dollars of our money let's see
everything with the good use hey look a
goat millions of dollars have been spent
around this area most noteworthy would
be 3.4 million to the North Shore Yacht
Club here in the Salton Sea we're
looking for it I I think this is it
I just got an email it's actually 3.5
million not that it matters but so this
is what 3.5 million gets you uh an old
glue can and the Carl's jr. cup I get
that this could actually be a really
nice place but is it really something
that you think our tax dollars should
pay for if it were worth fixing up the
only thing private enterprises would
step in and do it themselves I don't
know 3.5 m/s really did you book the
hotel tonight
the hotel
when I'm joking you didn't book the
hotel in the hotel take care of these
things you take care of their kin right
you booked the hotel
give me a dinner you said we're going
east I just said that I just I just say
things I say we're playing it by ear all
the time then I go where we're gonna be
for lunch I'm playing it by ear
what
you'll pay me well somebody is
so we're just filling up on gas here in
the middle of the desert we pass the
salt sea a while back and we're just
gonna find out we're also saving this
money being spent
so it's an epic journey my friends we'll
keep you posted
how we doing back there good now you've
got to understand that the road can take
its toll on people especially when
things get dicey Steve why did you only
put 15 bucks in that's all ahead I'm not
hearing this that's what you do
do you have any idea where we're going
boss the map says it's over there I we
got to go somewhere this we've walked
for a mile there's nothing there what do
you want to go I mean there's nothing
out here this is your this is your job
we should just leaders to take care of
okay you're supposed to take care of
these things I'm supposed to sit here
I'm supposed to tape it and I couldn't
wait I write it and what you do is you
prepare everything okay and you didn't
prepare anything we live in a 1 motel
room ha Steve the PA from Iowa has gone
what appears to be completely insane I
think it's due to stress possible
heatstroke is not a good situation
come on Steve come on man you want to go
to friendlies you want to go to frit oh
no Steve
Steve PA from Iowa man are you okay are
you okay I'm sorry about the gas Steven
it's okay where's my headset
I'll get my headset your headset
don't you worry about Steve the PA from
Iowa we got him home yeah we got him
home
we were actually making pretty good time
on the road so we decided to stop and
pick ourselves up some hot dates Oh then
we decided to check out another stimulus
project that showed up on our radar so
you are looking at another stimulus
project 1.3 mile walking path around
Lake ladybird formerly Lake Austin in
Austin Texas 18 million dollars you're
looking at it say about the bike path
see what they say
see you President Obama I walk away from
you and your stimulus actually I think I
found some bread
about 18 million nice it's nice I'll
admit it at this point I was starting to
get a little upset you've made a monkey
out of me but how could you not with all
this spending it seems only natural to
be a bit perturbed need more proof so we
are right outside the Dallas Convention
Center where if you look behind me right
here there's a lot 386 million dollars
of stimulus money will be going into
building a hotel right here 386 million
dollars you'd better get a mint on your
pillow they actually spend millions of
dollars on signs for the recovery and
investment program to let people know
that your tax dollars aren't worth here
they put a sign right in the ground so
some of them can actually be three
thousand dollars a piece
it's government efficiency for you and
those were just the places we weren't
denied entry often times you were
quickly escorted from the premises which
to be sure is because I'm white one will
it end America so we've just decided to
list some other interesting stimulus
projects going on across the country are
you ready okay 20 million for downtown
quiet down in San Diego two point one
six billion for Los Angeles solar
projects 500,000 for dog park and Chula
Vista California six million trying to
make a golf course in Arlington Texas
275 million for Performing Arts Center
in las vegas nevada not a strip club
five million for an Arts and Culture
Center in Anchorage Alaska 4.5 million
for Washington matter pool construction
San Leandro California five thousand for
a skate park in luton Idaho 30 million
for an alternative fuel bus in Tucson
Arizona and the list goes on folks now I
know the argument for all these silly
projects is oh those projects creating
new jobs well that can't be true despite
Barack Obama's promise that unemployment
would never reach 8% if this world were
to be passed at the time of this video
it's only reached nine point four
because the key word here is new jobs
not additional now see if I were to eat
part of this banana and toss the rest of
it on the floor
oh [ __ ] can you get that for me
now see that right there is a new job
for Steve but not an additional one in
the santa truth is that ultimately these
new jobs have a mere lifespan of an
average of 35 hours per worker no not
per week total because by the state's
accounting a job as a job whether it's
two minutes or two years so after an
average total of one workweek the
workers back to square one but what
about you folks watching at home have
you received any stimulus money how has
it affected you personally be sure to
leave your comment and let me know the
good news is that we can do something we
can stop this in 2010 by electing the
right officials as for me and Steve the
PA from Iowa well we'll continue to
brave the road so you don't have to